we are all so capable of such incredible
Feats no matter what your area of
specialization or what your Pursuits we
mostly can go so much further than we
ever see ourselves going and it's so
important where we see ourselves how we
see ourselves is one of the most
important things in the world so I mean
for example well I I'd love to be a fast
marathoner but I always envisioned
myself as being like maybe for a long
time it was like a 4-Hour marathoner and
then somewhere along the line I start
see myself as Maybe at 3:30 and then
maybe 3:15 and then I well maybe I can
be a sub three-h hour so I got to
245 58 and now I'm like you know I'm not
sure if that's like my Pinnacle or maybe
I can actually go further than that even
though I'm at my age right now 47 it
seems
counterintuitive my PR is from four
years ago you know maybe it is actually
possible if I concentrate my energies
and also adopt the knowledge that's
available to make that happen